our series our more perfect union aims
to show that what unites us as Americans
is greater than what divides us in
Milwaukee hundreds of homes have been
revitalized because of a chance
encounter between two people
chip Reid caught up with the couple who
set out to end the housing blight and
rebuild their neighborhood one home at a
time Sharon and Larry Adams are bringing
life back to their boarded up
neighborhood while giving hope to many
who live here when I was younger this
neighbor who had a lot of gang banging
going on a lot of drugs a lot of
destruction over here and I was part of
the destruction know now love that first
bloomed here when Sharon moved into her
childhood home it needed work and Larry
an electrical contractor came by to take
a look a first meeting that was well
electric and she says do you want some
tea at the time I'm drinking maybe a pot
of coffee a day smoking two packs of
cigarettes a day and I'm moving and I
say yes Sharon hired him but love got in
the way after i rewired the house I
fired myself because that's the conflict
of interest working the past two decades
with the help of donations to restore
more than a hundred homes in this
stretch of the city blighted by riots
has never happened here in Milwaukee and
neglect that left their neighborhood
classified as undesignated 2,700 people
house I'm designating which means you're
irrelevant to us right and we looked at
each other to say the unlikely spark for
change happened right on their street we
see lights flickering outside of the
house drug activity and what were those
lights crack pipes crack pipes and is
that one of the moments when the two of
you decided we've got to do something
about this I asked you to fix it you and
you asked him to fix it did you say
please I did think as always please I
mean look at those eyes as always please
but to grow up
unity you have to start with a seed so
they also planted Gardens even orchards
42 piece trees so we have or choose
enough orchard in Milwaukee in Milwaukee
of all places great you have bees making
honey
creating a buzz that brought businesses
including the neighborhoods first
restaurant a juice bar and opportunity
for people like Darius Wade and Henry
Hopkins did you ever think you'd be a
role model back in the days I want to be
a different role model you know I want
to be the biggest drug dealer you know I
want to look here look up at me doing
that now Hopkins runs a different kind
of crew a landscaping crew launched by
the Adams as to beautify these blocks
every day they pushing me Larry tell me
you got plans for me
Hopkins has plans to to start his own
business while Wade has another idea for
improving these streets I always wanted
to be a police officer I wanted so that
you can grow up in this area and still
make it out and be somebody all possible
because one loving couple cared what
have they done for you a lot of the
credit while they credit each other what
is it that drives you to keep going
and belief that what they've done here
is part of something much bigger
we're not the beginning you're a link in
a chain we and so I am so grateful oh
yeah to you for CBS this morning chip
Reid in Milwaukee a link in the chain
and they will not be the end it just
shows you if people think you care about
them the difference that it makes and
sometimes all you need is one person's
right just show you you know our city's
Q matter yeah they can be cetera I love
Milwaukee already I'd say what it is